a former maximum Playboy model sentenced
today for her role in a 2019 murder
Thomas Bouchard's beaten body was found
dumped in the desert near Lake Mead Ryan
mathey in the courtroom today with the
emotional plea from the victim's fiancee
for the maximum sentence
a transactional relationship that's how
the Clark County DA's office describes
Kelsey Turner and Thomas Bouchard and
after Bouchard cut her off her and her
boyfriend murdered him according to the
state and Tuesday Morning the ex-model
faced her fade you're hereby sentence to
10 to 20 five years from the Nevada
Department about corrections that fate
revealed to the 29 year old for the
murder of the 71 year old California
psychiatrist Thomas burchard
Deputy district attorney Pamela weckerly
points to this evidence where police
found the body in the trunk of a car
near Lake Mead the investigation did
reveal Bouchard paid her rent and the
two had a relationship
when he tried to cut it off she alleged
the California man had pornographic
photos of minors on his phone her then
boyfriend 29 year old John Kennison
assisting in the eventual murder
prosecutors say the accusation was false
and guinnesson was sentenced to 18 to 45
years over the summer
his last words to his longtime partner
Judy Erp she tells 8 news now that
Turner stole over three hundred thousand
dollars from him but because of the
Alford plea she accepted in November
Turner is guaranteed the possibility of
parole after 10 years
of my life constantly worrying you and
always looking over my shoulder
prosecutors also pointed out Turner
attempted to profit off this case by
setting up a GoFundMe to pay for her
attorney she also unsuccessfully
negotiated to start in a reality show
that followed the lives of felons and
their significant others